قال القيادي في حركه المقاومه الاسلاميه
حماس اسامه حمدان ان قتل الاحتلال لحد
الان ل 109 صحفيين اخرهم حمزه الدحدوح نجل
الزميل وائل الدحدوح امر متعمد يعني سقوط
الروايه الاسرائيليه للعدوان واضاف حمدان
ان استهداف الصحفيين لن يمنع العالم من
معرفه حقيقه ما يقع في غزه من
جرائم لقد طالت جرائم الاحتلال كذلك
الصحفيين في عمليه
قتل متعمد وبلغ عدد الصحفيين الذين ارتقوا
حتى الساعه
109 من الصحفيين اخرهم الشهيد حمزه
الدحدوح نجلى الصحفي وائل الدحدوح والصحفي
الشهيد مصطفى ثريا والصحفي الشهيد علي ابو
عجوه ان هذه الجرائم المتتابعه في استهدام
الص في استهداف الصحفيين لا تعني الا شيئا
واحدا
سقوط الروايه الصهيونيه للعدوان ومحاوله
هذا الكيان تكميم افواه الحقيقه وقتلها
قبل ان تصل الى الناس
لينفضوا الى العالم الذي بات يرى هذا
الكيان رؤيه واضحه كيانا ارهابيا نازيا
قاتلا